So personally, I would say no, this
is not a good way to reason over it.
We talked about in the previous portion
of the lesson that Metacognition
uses the same strategies
that it reasons over.
It reasons over case based reasoning.
It reasons over means and analysis.
It reasons over problem reduction.
But it also uses case based reasoning,
problem reduction, means and analysis
and the others to do that reasoning.
So it really doesn't need an additional
layer, it's already equipped with
the ability to reason over case based
reasoning in the other methods, so
it can just reason over itself.
>> This is really cool, so agents don't
need multiple levels of Metacognition
because Metacognition reasons
over itself recursively.
In fact, current theories of
Metacognition all talk about
this kind of two layer system between
Deliberation and Metacognition.